people bring their games we look at
their games that's cool anybody want to
be first victim step forward
yeah all right see what you got
Wow you're gonna active player okay so
you for six the French is really popular
around here huh I think I've seen like
ten games today five really French six
what was that
my bad so d5 Knight c3 Knight f6 should
be fine
Bishop you said you don't like the
Bishop before line man like when I used
to play the French I used to love
playing this Bishop before stuff like
all the but the King F a light you know
not the g6 one all right I saw some
fortunate games and I was just like
blown away I'm like how did like he just
takes the attack and then just wins the
endgame
alright so II 597 you're not scared of
the h4 stuff and I'll do you take the
pawn yeah like after h4 oh okay I see
smart man
so but you didn't do that you just
traded way by the way what I'm talking
about is this is a move that world
champion at name alekhine kind of made
popular and it involves just sacrificing
this pawn here on g5 and in exchange
what white gets is some very interesting
pressure along the H file and usually
this Queen will get kicked out and
White's pieces have a lot of space on
the Kings side just to put pressure
especially on this pawn on g7 and in the
meantime all of blacks pieces are
completely undeveloped so it's a very
tricky opening and with you know
throughout the years there's been a lot
of theory developed so that's why I was
asking him you know where he gets the
courage but you don't take the pawn so
what do you do after h4
would they chore okay interesting all
right I guess
every time I looked at it it's like
everybody plays each war and they take
everything excellent age five it's kind
of unusual Queens is coming out and the
King's not even on the Kings side yet
did you did you Castle kingside yeah I
would have tried to I don't know done
something psychological you know like
try to Castle queenside be like look
where you put your queen yeah yeah see
you like for example what I would want
to do is usually place five but here I
think I might run into some trouble
after net Knight b5 which is I think
kind of a typical idea that white has in
these setups yeah so I mean if you take
on d4 then I have this Knight d6 check
and that doesn't look very pretty so
keeping that in mind what I was thinking
since I don't want a castle yeah I'm not
saying the castle is bad I'm just saying
I'm thinking out loud like what like if
I just looked at this position and
someone played Queen h5 I'd be like I'm
gonna Castle kingside so a move that
would come to my mind would be a6 which
spoiler alert is planning c5 and all I
want to do is just prevent this Knight
from coming to b5 so that's one idea but
I'm sure it's just fine
so Bishop b3 h6
you felt safe yeah and you just played
this game so it's all fresh in your mind
just trying to yeah
I was looking at f5 I'm not sure if that
would be like a good move because if
your opponent doesn't take this pawn on
pass on then it's it looks like you've
closed down the Kings side and you're
ready to play C 5 yeah yeah I would take
with the night and I think French
players aren't usually too scared of
this backward pawn as long as you have
this Bishop you can defend it pretty
easily and what feels nice about this is
that I'm winning a tempo over this Queen
that came out so early so I feel like
I'm doing something right you know like
like I'm punishing someone that's trying
to violate my dear classical principles
so let's go back here so h6 as long as
you don't play this move I'm happy
before and then you went knight c6
without c5 cuz you're gonna get night
before interesting and there's nothing
you can do about that
see I mean in the French defense I'm I'm
usually thinking that black is always
gonna play c5 and try to put pressure on
d4 so when I see a move like knight c6 I
get worried because if if I don't get
something real against d4 white is gonna
have all the time in the world to just
start storming my Kings side so if
against the move did he yeah he played
Knight f3 black has this very timely
move Knight before which if you didn't
have night before I would be very
critical of knight c6 right because I
mean you're blocking yeah okay so that's
very nice and if you can get rid of this
Bishop that's that's a huge
accomplishment yeah so nice c6 looks
like a very interesting move the minute
because I was trying to find something
to give you a hard time maybe I could
castle that way against the night before
and I could move the bishop away but you
always have c5 so it seems to work out
just fine so net before castle
and c5 and actually I think I've seen
quite a few games where black doesn't
really take on d4 he just plays c4 and
and then you know you just swing
everything over
it's a g4 f6 what's the idea behind f6
I'm just afraid that it that it's just
gonna enable wait to open up there
the King's had it okay he did just play
g4 yeah so I mean the first thing I
would do is I would chop this guy down
yeah because I I know this guy's gonna
go because that's the whole idea of
night before so I think he would take
with the rook it makes sense right
and now maybe I could start winning some
some tempos so rook t2 probably and
you're saying that now g5 was a movie or
having trouble with
yeah I think that's a pretty accurate
evaluation because this position looks
really bad to me for black already so
this is leading me to question the the
whole maybe quick castling with h6
because if this pawn was on h7 I don't
know if I would be that worried because
g5 isn't really gonna do anything but
now all of a sudden this contact point
is giving you all sorts of trouble and I
don't see any counter play for back for
black yeah it is on before sorry so I
can I think now I can understand a
little bit better yeah yeah I think
you're right and also I think your your
judgment is probably correct in what you
think because there's might be some
Bishop g6 okay alright but here he
played g5 and you took it so there
really didn't didn't make a difference
so f takes f6 well at least now you're
getting you're getting the F file for
your work but this this just seems like
it's gonna be a chronic problem and I
mean yeah okay so you played rogue f5 I
don't practice of you think we know
seven looks interesting did you see
anything that kind of yeah I mean that's
that's a very French state of mind when
you see this you just want to put a
[ __ ] over here you might even be in
denial that it's just never gonna happen
you know cuz for that to happen you
would need this and somehow this and
even if that happens it's not clear like
what's better but yeah sometimes you
gotta weigh what you want with what you
need here and I think you just need to
get the Queen's off I mean unless
there's something really the wreck that
I'm missing I would just try to trade
Queens and White has to be careful
because if he thinks he has all the time
in the world you also have some counter
play here based on taking on d4 and
thing any client so looking for
see takes
and rookie 5
and right there I thought
he played rook Jiwon and this thing and
d500 always check right of course
oh I see it okay that I mean I mean I
just kept thinking that King was still
um do you want okay alright let's let's
look at this line first
yeah well sorry hang on d3 and now hang
on if I right so if I take on d5 you
have some interesting checks there yeah
and if I take care you want to play
check and and take or what happens if I
take
yeah and actually outs I mean earlier we
were talking about domination and how
it's just limiting the scope of your
enemies pieces or your opponent's pieces
so I keep thinking that against takes
there might be some queen III stuff and
if gainst Knight takes d5 there might be
some Queen c5 so I was just looking at
this move King Ditu which has its idea
mainly I was looking at what would
happen if d4 than rook e1 and if takes
pawn takes and now it's kind of miss
Bishop e6 because I thought you know if
you move the Queen then I just play rook
e8 and it looks like checkmate almost
but almost doesn't cut it so so King bee
2 is just delirium
it looks like an interesting position
I'm just a little bit concerned that
this bishops not coming out yet but it
yeah so yeah I mean there seem to be two
moves to consider G takes and they takes
d5 if Knight takes though check King V 1
so if Queen takes Queen checking h7 g6
checkmate it's kind of cool but I don't
think you need to do that to yourself
maybe you can just go over v6 and this
position is a total mess but I don't
know I I just have a gut feeling that
white has to be doing ok has to be doing
more than okay
I know this moves like Knight f6
floating around I'm not sure what to
make of them even even probably a move
like Knight f4 might be okay just
threatening the bishop and putting the
nine on a good square yeah cuz I don't
think there's any any captures on a two
that I need to worry about so okay so
maybe your your fear here is justified
because this position looks forced and
it doesn't look so hot for black
so you took with the rook on e5 right so
rook takes instead of Knight takes e5
rook g1 now it also seems like your
opponent's it's not really and you know
getting this Queen out of the way to
open up the G foul he's taking too long
okay again maybe a move I would consider
between f7 I don't know if it works here
though I mean it's like a whole bunch of
other stuff going on now oh you got you
got your move in on the night of it and
I bet that felt good yeah exactly
Queen g4 okay now we're talking Knight
g6
what's going on what happens it takes
you wait Knight f3 what's wrong with
this mouth
am I doing this right okay
still because this is what happened in
the game I think you played Knight f3
but this move begs the question
there doesn't seem to be a good way to
defend
oh my my mistake sorry so again it's
queen g4 you took on g5 before you put
yeah yeah yeah my mistake
yeah that makes a lot more sense so now
no g6 that looks nicer now just scaring
you so night h4 95
ix - oh right you can't take here you're
gonna get made on the H file yeah so 95
night takes d3 check now at least you're
winning a temple on the Queen as opposed
to those other lines where the Queen was
on h5 and you don't have to deal with
the G takes h6 stuff so yeah this is a
much better version and you're up a pond
right nice nice Queen d4 oh now you're
golden
now it's smooth sailing now you got your
pieces out you're up upon C file is open
nice yeah I think yeah you you were
probably feeling pretty good now huh
okay yeah as is always a bad sign when
you need to be attacking and you have to
play like kings you want
yeah you still have to be careful though
you have no control over dark squares
and you're a little--you're King is a
little bit smothered here
okay doesn't look like there's anything
really problematic
yeah I really like where you positioned
your book first of all because not only
are you giving a nice escape route for
your King you know in case you need it
which wouldn't be ideal you know if you
have to start doing this but you're also
putting pressure on g6 and last but not
least you're also preparing to to
advance this f-pawn so I think rogue f8
rogue f6 is a really nice defensive
maneuver just because it does so much
you know at once and usually I think
that's the trademark of you know a good
move or just a good idea in general if
if you can do several things at the same
time then you're being very efficient
with your moves
so after rook f6
yeah it's very nice it reminds me of
some of those quarter games in the
McCutchin where you know this queen it
just gets in you end up doing something
like that okay
oh man that that turned around pretty
quick now all of a sudden this bishops a
beast
it's it's game over almost right he has
to go in I see one right now oh he
played a night at four
I mean he's either got to play b3 or
night see one right I would think that
the problem with night c1 maybe is you
know you can play this f4 move I don't
know that's it's one idea unless there's
like a clean h3 or something really
dangerous but if I can just get this
this F pawn rolling I'd be feeling
pretty good I mean I feel pretty good
already but what was your general idea
here okay yeah
I mean that makes sense the only thing
I'd be concerned about is move like
Queen h3 just I don't get made it but I
don't think there's anything
Yeah right I mean I'm looking at a
couple moves I was looking at Queen f5
or maybe you just queen c6 I like Queen
Queen c6 because Queen f5 doesn't really
you know change anything we're all just
shuffling back and forth and I still
have to deal with the main threats so
Queen c6 I like because again it's a
dominating move I'm just covering the
squares that you want to get to and
moving like Queen of five just delays
the same question because after Queen f3
we still have to deal with the same
problem just on a different square so
this nips it right in the bud just want
to make sure I'm not missing like mating
2 or something is that would be
embarrassing okay yeah I mean there's no
way for this Queen to get to the e-file
maybe a move like I don't know Queen h2
just anticipating it if you go f3 then
Queen b8 it's going to end up being
checkmate so maybe something like that
all right but definitely I mean night
see one seems to be the the key move or
the only move b3 is probably worse
because you actually want to clear up
the e-file for the rook so yeah so this
is bad news
me too
well you're this totally redeeming for
the French bishop
everybody says that Bishop is bad
checkmate in your face society yeah now
I think that was a very interesting game
I mean you have to be cold-blooded to
handle those positions I don't think I
can do it but I do think something went
wrong in that opening for you because
that position looked way too scary I
don't know if I would criticize castling
I am NOT crazy about h6
I think maybe f5 and and already just
start trying to bring your pieces over
to the Kings side because it takes the
knight takes f6 and you're starting with
tempos on the Queen and you know maybe
you can get this knight c6 Bishop e7 e8
stuff going a little bit quicker because
as it happened in the game I mean all of
all of whites play was was already
rolling and all you had was this night
before stuff and it was like that's not
gonna be enough but but it worked out so
ok interesting game this is nice I don't
know if we should look at it well he's
not here though like we're doing it
behind his back oh you can see you later
okay Mike Mike Mike from the future okay
okay so Mike is white and then Feingold
is black so d4 look at that I can I can
sense the fear it's like this this is
the I have a feelings as far as this
pawn is gonna go for a while gonna play
it close to the chest so Mike is playing
white and black is Ben Feingold so takes
actually I just saw a game a friend of
mine a Grand Master from Paraguay you
know he's he's like 20 years old and
he's been winning like every tournament
in Europe recently and he's you know his
rating is skyrocketing his name is axel
Bachman and
the main idea that Trump OSI is that
white wants to double up these pawns and
you know have all these types of
positions with better pawn structure and
it's for a long time it was just
considered that after Bishop takes f6
these positions are unpleasant for black
or you know either etags or gtex but I
saw I saw this guy played G takes and
win a really nice really nice game
against one that when he's Hungarian
2700 it's a Richard rapport I think he
was playing in the US a while ago so
this is really making me question the
validity of this assumption that you
know if you let black take on f6 I mean
if you let white take on f6 that things
are so easy so I I think the c5 move
goes along those lines because after
Bishop takes G takes we get a similar
idea except that there's a pawn on c5
instead of d5 so after actually the pawn
they go to d5 nice no Queen b6 usually
when white takes on f6 the general
strategy is to keep all your pawns on
dark squares because you just lost your
dark square bishop so you need to make
up for it by just putting as many pawns
in dark squares as possible usually that
that means putting your pawns c3 on e3
and many times that the light square
bishop gets developed through g2 so this
is very consistent with your general
strategy of putting as many pawns in
dark squares as you can that way you
won't really miss it that much and all
the while it's not clear what black is
going to do about is king because if he
castles King side well now that the
weakening of the pawn structure is
really really obvious this Queen can
very easily come to h5 Knight can come
to e2 and f4 but
theory says that d5 is the main move so
after Queen b6 b3 I think most people
play Queen c1 and I remember shear off
playing this with black and of course
shear off being not that he is just
placed like Bishop h6 so if you take the
bishop I take the pawn and we have you
know some crazy tactics going on of
course we can just go III and the game
goes on
but b3 is a move that worries me a
little bit not because it's you know a
bad move in itself but because black is
really kind of poking at white and
making him do things he doesn't really
want to do because before we were
looking at where all our pawn should be
going and now it's like they're going in
the opposite places and it's happening
almost you know you know so slowly that
you can't really notice it because being
I guess that's what GM's usually do you
know they make you do things and you
don't really realize that they're doing
it and here I'm starting to notice one
of those things because I would not want
to put my pawns on five squares so
f-five and i think this is why because
now this bishop is gonna come to g7 and
this whole diagonal is gonna be a mess
c3 okay since e3
maybe six
yeah obviously black had to get creative
developing this night because if you go
to d7 right away you have some problems
defending f5 so in any case I think c7
is a really good square for the night
because it puts pressure on d5 and it
also prepares this move east six when
the time is right so black is also
getting ready to put some serious
pressure on the white center so I have
four should be five
I think black is anticipating some
possible night h5 stuff and as well as
threatening to take on that four and
then it take on d5 so clean to h5 then
you chopped it down
then he took undue you fine yeah
so if if black can just take on d5
without any serious consequences in this
queen h5 moon really wasn't a good idea
probably the right thing to do here
would be to defend it on d5 somehow I'm
sure there's a way I mean I would think
about a move like Queen f3 maybe the
problem is I can never really finish my
development especially with this night
on b1 because whenever I move this night
then my opponent c3 is gonna be hanging
that's why it's so important to have
kept the pawn on b2 otherwise I might
have to do something like jeez I don't
know like Bishop c2 that way if Bishop
takes pawn takes now the Queen is
defending d5 and maybe I can prepare
something like Queen d2 and then maybe
93-94 just holding all the pieces
together barely but at least holding
after Queen age five I think White's
position finally collapses takes
ninety-five
Bishop c4 Bishop e6 yeah I think white
just missed it after Bishop e6 there's
really no pressure on f7 and now the
knight can move to either f6 or just
stay on d5 and black it's just up upon
and it's ahead and development too and I
mean actually it's white that has all
the palm weaknesses that shouldn't
happen
the trompe asking so he took here
now he gets this pawn back but this pawn
is gone now yeah I'm I'm not convinced
this is a good pawn trade just because
this pawn structure is much worse than
this one by the simple fact that now
there's nobody to defend these isolated
pawns particularly the pawn on f4 it
looks like g3 that would at least keep
everything in one Pine Island I think I
would have just preferred to keep my
pawn on g2 and allow black to keep his
pawn on f5 and just defend g2 how that
is a good question
maybe I can castle but then one was like
rook g8 or kind of troubling but but
okay I think I can deal with this so now
I'm actually threatening to take on f5
I'm also considering to playing c4 and
Knight c3 and there's some coherence to
the white set up and in for a g8 I'm not
really that worried because I'm not
mistaken I can just go g3 and sure my
light scores aren't pretty hey life's
not perfect but now I'm threatening two
pawns instead of one and again c4 Knight
c3 if I can get the Knight to d5 and
black this diagonal I don't know if if
white has that much to worry about
so after Queen f5 Bishop g2
4126
yeah obviously if if black is able to
trade Queens the pawn structure greatly
favors and so hopefully Mike didn't try
it on d5 come on Mike
oh nice screen g4 I was terrified
Oh Rick d1 oh this is kind of funny so
why can't he just castle instead of
playing Rick do you want
is this funny maybe not
because it seems more natural to castle
right I mean you don't want to leave
your King in the center like that yeah
that's what I was looking at but I think
they take c4 might not be terrible
because after Queen takes I can just
play rook e1 and all of a sudden there's
like stuff it doesn't look too too hot I
would be a little bit scared if I was
black here but I think black has I don't
know if this is what Ben had in mind but
after castles I'm thinking black has
this note first and obviously the idea
is that if you go to a random square
then Queen d3 is much much stronger now
so 94 doesn't do anything and Queen c2
seems like a good move so you probably
have to go somewhere along the
third-ranked
can I get away with that are you that
cool you can get away with that yeah so
against Queen d3 here
we're now hotshot you do that but then
just rook takes and take and then just
gonna hd3 I'm still in the game but I
think after Queen takes Knight you still
got everything you want right you still
got everything you want right after
three days yeah it works look it looks
like it works but they're probably queen
g3 or Queen f3 I don't know it should be
the same but Queen g3 looks like the
more natural move but I think then you
can just go Queen d3 and black wanted to
trade Queens anyway so now black just
gets that endgame you want it before and
rook H e1 doesn't seem like a big deal
anymore you probably just get away with
going here and blacks just a pawn up
right yeah
this is here so so you play Rick do you
want instead of castling the only
problem is now you never have
Ricky one oh so you just want Fischer to
see - okay so I work the always a bad
move because now you can't even keep
your rook on d1 so after rook c1 Bishop
f5
right Oh Castle Mike forgot to put the
second zero your third zero yeah and
this looks over this is not a good setup
and black king is safe I mean you're
getting killed and light squares you
can't take on e7 because of the the pin
on the e-file then this game is pretty
much over so
or I took country 3
check this
greenish
all right so now why it's just gonna
lose another pond and this king is still
exposed I think oh he didn't even take
the pond interesting you just won't
check that
King D - oh so this was his idea
now d5 and the D fall is gonna open up
been so good I would just take in the
pond and they're like hey 1 D 3 yeah
it's not good is this D 6 that's not a
move that doesn't make sense though well
why would you play p6 here yeah it says
d6o work these six maybe but I'm not
sure that makes a lot of sense you know
at first I thought he had Queenie one
but then I guess Queen D 1 is the only
move otherwise Queen takes c3 the funny
thing is afterwards it says white played
King G 2 which which I mean doesn't
resonate so well with the position see
what else is oh then a 6 and then King
to r3 and he sunk his battleship so
alright it's lost anyway so I think I
think that'll be it for this game